foreign
[Music]
anything else
cool um
hello everyone welcome to the second day
of the dynamic graphs Workshop
um we have four blocks four talks 10 for
today and the first stock will be it by
so hell and they'll be on recent
progress on sublinear time algorithms
for maximum matching and Sohail is an
assistant professor at of computer
science at Northeastern University with
a broad interest in theater computer
science
he receives his PhD from the University
of Maryland where he was advised by
Muhammad
before joining Northeastern he was a
manwani postdoc at Stanford hosted by
Moses Rubenstein I'm in Siberia in the
young tan
and most of his much of his research
revolves around sublinear time
algorithms parallel algorithms streaming
algorithms Dynamic arms and craft stores
vacation
um
okay
um hello everybody good morning I'll be
talking about a recent progress on stop
the anytime algorithms for maximum
matching
um I I've been given two talks um one
talk today will be specifically focused
on upper bounds on algorithms and the
talk on Friday really mostly focus on
Lower bounds
um but this is a workshop on Dynamic
algorithms so I'll actually discuss and
motivate sublinear time algorithms for
maximum matching via Dynamic algorithms
a good portion of the stock will
actually be about this connection
um
so I start by defining matchings
um so what are the matching and matching
is the setup vertex disjoint edges the
red edges your former matching and the
maximum matching is a matching of
largest possible size
um so the maximum matching problem has
numerous applications
um I won't be going through all of these
applications but basically it has many
applications in kidney Exchange image
recognition online advertisement labor
markets and resource allocation in
general
um okay
so the maximum matching problem has been
studied for nearly
um
from a combinatorial perspective that's
been studied for more than a century but
algorithmically it's been
mostly started since the work of Edmonds
from 1960s who first showed that the
maximum matching problem can be solved
in polynomial time he gave an M times N
squared time algorithm where
um
we will use and throughout the talk to
denote the number of vertices and M to
denote the number of edges in the graph
so there's been a lot of
um subsequent Works
um here's what we know
um this is this is basically the state
of the art for General graphs an
algorithm of mikalia and vasirani from
uh 80s obtains an M times root n time
algorithm which remains a state of the
art for General graphs for both parted
graphs uh finally after a long line of
work uh last year we got a
um uh near almost linear time algorithm
by China Doll uh for uh the case where
the graph is bipartite and also I want
to point out that if you relax maximum
matching to a 1 minus Epsilon
approximate matching which is a matching
that's at least a one or minus Epsilon
as large times as large as the maximum
matching then there's a simple algorithm
by hobcraft and car from 70s that
obtains this matching in linear time M
over Epsilon time
it works for non-biparate as well if you
want uh approximation it works for
non-pilot drives as well
I thought it's 250 but
approach cup looks for uh shorter
mending paths where I didn't type stuff
right so it'll be
just for micro digress
uh I see okay okay thanks uh yeah so so
anyway so so the point is that if we
relax it to about myself some
approximations we have um simple linear
time algorithms yeah so this yeah
I thought it's the second phase that
only requires
um the graph to be my part but um yeah
so
um thanks um okay so what we'll focus on
today is can we actually design
algorithms uh that can go below linear
time in the number of edges of the graph
algorithms that take less than N squared
time if the graph is dense or
um
basically just just a running time
that's uh that that cannot be as large
as N squared
um so this is the question that we focus
on today
um and as I said this is strongly
motivated by Dynamic graph algorithms
um
so
today I'll first talk about the general
model of sub linear time uh graph
algorithms and then I'll talk about the
connection to Dynamic algorithms and
then tell you more about sub linear
algorithm so maximum matching what we
know what we do not
okay
um so let's start with the model so
whenever you talk about
um sub linear time algorithms it's
important to specify how the input is
represented so there are two types of
representations that are commonly
studied for graph algorithms
um one is the adjacency list model and
one is the adjacency matrix model so in
the first one you have the list of the
neighbors of each vertex you can query
any entry of these arrays
and on the adjacency matrix model you
have an N by n Matrix and a Boolean
Matrix and you can also query entries of
this Matrix
and
um yeah so here the response would be
the ID of the neighbor here the response
is whether the two query verses are
adjacent or not
um so
for the for the adjacency list model the
trivial algorithm is to query everything
um the sum of lengths of these arrays
are some of the degrees which is upper
bounded by the number of some type of
upper Bound by the number of edges of
the graph so this is order amp queries
for the object symmetrics model is it's
N squared queries so this is the trivial
argument you learn the whole graph and
then you can run your
substance around linear
algorithm obtained about myself
approximation
um
and immediately the bad news is that
these trivial algorithms are actually
the best we can hope for if the goal is
to find a constant approximation if you
want to find the edge set of any
constant approximate matching even if
the matching is say 100 times smaller
than the maximum matching you still have
to pay this these many queries
um so in a sense the the right question
uh for the sub-linear time uh maximum
matching problem is to instead of
finding the edges of the matching just
estimate the size of the output the size
of the maximum right so we are given a
graph we can access it either viajacency
list queries or we are just in some
Matrix queries
and we want to query less than all of
these entries and provide an estimation
on the size of the maximum match okay so
this is the problem
any questions yeah
so if the adjacency lists are sorted
does it make a difference that's a good
question
um yeah so so I'll provide an example
that if it's not sorted that's a problem
um and then
if it is sorted
um so maybe let me let me I should talk
about the the example so
before this there was another question
yeah yeah so one tricky question uh does
this previous roll down hold even
foreign
of the edges of the matching
ah okay
so are you given the number of edges in
the incident in each node the degree
okay
sample with uniformly from the edges uh
that's a good question
um so in this talk I'll be ignoring all
polydog factors
and if if you ignore all polyline
factors you can just buy in the research
so you get to the end and it says
um Okay so so let's see some trivial
lower balance so basically consider the
sentence the graph is either completely
empty or has just one Edge
and suppose that we have adjacency list
access to the graph so in the first case
the matching has size zero in the second
case it has size one on any
multiplicative approximation would have
to be able to distinguish the two cases
and for this we're going to have to make
omega n queries to the addresses the
list to find the vertex
um that has the edge if any okay so this
is a simple lower bound showing that
Omega n time is needed
um yeah a question was asked what
happens if uh the the lists are the the
adjustments of this are sorted
um
or if the vertices were sorted based on
degrees or or if the adjustments in this
first order
yeah so um so generally my intuition is
that degree is not really a that useful
for just um for solving matchings
um and yeah I have to think a little bit
more about this to see if it would make
a difference but but basically that
that's
um the second example shows why degrees
are not that useful
um so this is a lower bound
um by Partners Iran from 2007
um so actually going back
um in this example this is not really a
nice lower Bound in the sense that the
matching is just so small and in many
cases and we will see one we can
basically just assume that the matching
is large enough right so it's it's maybe
linear in the number of vertices and
this lower bound is really just for the
case when the matching is so small that
you have to just find one vertex
but basically
um the same lower amount of Omega and
can be extended to the case uh even if
we assume that the matching is Omega n
and this is the lower bound construction
so basically I'm just I'm not going to
spend too much time on this but
basically we have Epsilon and vertices
that are adjacent to every other vertex
in the graph and either you have a
matching among the rest of the vertices
or you have nothing among the rest of
the vertices and to find the so if you
want to say if you want to find if this
vertex has an edge or not adjacent to
another vertex of the core not these
dummy Epsilon and verses you're going to
have to go over all of its edges to find
one so this is intuitively why Omega n
is needed
um although here the degrees of these
vertices are different so you can
immediately say which instance your
graph is from
um but that that's easy to fix you can
just add this at two stars like this and
that makes all the degrees the same
except for one for two vertices that
have large degrees here and small
degrees here but even finding these two
verses would be hard so I think this is
yeah I'm not going to spend too much
time on this this I just wanted to say
Omega n is needed even if the matching
is large and you have adjacent to this
access to the graph
um yeah and here yeah so as you see like
all the verses here have the same
degrees except these two vertices kind
of that
um still the the size of the matchings
of these two graphs are very different
um okay
any questions so far
um
so this linear and and lower bound was
all we knew
um up until very recently so this year
uh with Muhammad was sitting there and
an aviad
um we were able to show that if the goal
is to obtain a sufficiently large
approximation of Maximum matching namely
a slightly better than two-thirds
approximation then you're gonna have to
stand super linear in the number of
vertices time uh specifically we showed
that you're gonna have to spend n to the
1.2 time at least if you want to provide
an estimation of the size of the maximum
matching that gives a better than
two-thirds approximation
um yeah so so so I just wanted to give a
glimpse of what lower bounds are known
um there's another lower bound also for
bonuses approximations
um in low degree graphs would I not talk
about those yeah
time here you've been problems yeah yeah
sorry I'm missing something super
obvious like why is this stronger than
the previous lower Bond oh the previous
lower bound was
Omega n
so you're gonna need to spend linear in
the number of notes time yeah and then
the other one and if this works for any
constant approximation and the other one
has a has the assumption that you want a
good enough approximation but the lower
one on the number of probes is much
larger
you're gonna need to spend much more
time 10 to 1.2 time
okay sorry I I misread it's not n half
yeah okay yeah it's not a square root
then
okay
um
are these examples
yes yeah this is this is a bipartograph
um I mean yeah this is not bypass you
can't make it but
is there is it obviously harder in the
uh
uh what was it the adjacency Matrix yeah
that's a good question so this lower
band only holds in the adjacents of this
model I mean what what's written on is
only is only written for the addresses
of this model we believe we can also get
it
um for the adjusting Matrix but it's not
written yet
but is there one which is obviously
harder than the other uh um
yeah my intuition was that adjacency
Matrix is harder from
the perspective of Designing algorithms
but then proving lower band's digest
into this are easier so it's a little
bit okay so there's no reduction from
one to two dollars
okay
um
all right
okay so now
um yeah and I'll talk much more about
this construction on Friday so if you
like lower bounds um
and you're around
um yeah so I'll talk more about this one
right okay
um and what do we know
um so I'm just going to summarize
um the state of the art so they're
they're extensive works on sublinear
algorithms for matchings I'll talk about
them just to give you uh a sense of what
is possible this is this is what we know
is that you can obtain a half
approximation in linear in end time and
poly login time
um so in
so going back to this lower bound it
says that this lower band can be matched
up to polydog factors if you want half
approximation in other words the
assumption
that we want better than two-thirds so
some assumption on the approximation
issue is needed if you want a super
linear lower bound
okay
so yeah so we have basically right now
that the search of the art is three
algorithms one is half approximation in
linear and end time we can do a slightly
better than half approximation and near
linear yeah it's not nearly but it's n
to one plus Epsilon for any small
Epsilon this this Epsilon Prime and
Epsilon are related
so you can make this as small as you
want it will affect how much better than
half you'll be
um and there is a
recent
um one minus substance approximation in
sub quadratic Time by Cheyenne Peter and
touchable
so this is what we know
um
but right now I actually want to switch
a dynamic algorithms and first motivate
the study of sub-linear algorithms via
Dynamic algorithms
so I started by defining the dynamic
matching problem so what is the dynamic
matching problem
so we have a graph
that is subject to Edge insertions and
deletions
and at any time we want to maintain
either the edge set or the size
um of the maximum matching approximately
okay so ideally we want to maintain the
exit of the matching
um
if we have that we also have the size
but as you will see maintaining the size
might be easier in some cases
so suppose that this is a graph now
um this is this is going to be the
maximum matching of the graph
maybe this Edge is inserted this doesn't
really increase the size of the matching
so maybe we can leave it as is
and then maybe like if this Edge is
deleted now it becomes important to
include Maybe
another Edge or maybe not
yeah I think
anyway yeah so you get the idea so the
main parameters to optimize for dynamic
matching are the approximation ratio how
large is the matching that you maintain
compared to the optimal solution
and the second one is how much time do
you spend per update okay so so an edge
is inserted or deleted how much time
this is time complexity how much time do
you need to address that update and in
return what is the approximation ratio
of the algorithm so these are two main
parameters but there are also a lot of
other important parameters to optimize
um for example whether the bound on the
update time is worst case or amortized
whether the algorithm is deterministic
or randomized whether the adversary is
oblivious or adaptive if the algorithm
is randomized
um
so there are other talks today I know
David will be talking about this
um in the interest of time I'll just
hide these
aspects of the algorithms that I'll talk
about I'll only focus on approximation
and update time in the stock
and there are a lot of works on Dynamic
matching so I won't be able to really
just um tell you about everything that's
known but I'll try to just give you an
overview of the of the bounds that are
known
um so
more than a decade ago
um plus one I'll show that you can
maintain a half approx a maximal
matching and a half approximation of
Maximum matching in login update time
um a few years later Bernstein on Stein
showed that you can maintain a
two-thirds approximation into 10 time so
you spend a little bit more time per
update in return you maintain a much
better approximation
and
Krypton pink also showed that you can
spend
um end time or more specifically root M
time Root the number of edges in the
graph and maintain about minus Epson
approximate matching
um so this was what we knew up until
around 2015-16 and since then there have
been a lot of
um new trade-offs between these so there
were a lot of Works
um achieving for example a slightly
worse approximation than two-thirds but
uh with a faster update time of n to the
one third or maybe like a
yeah slightly better than half
approximation in end to the Epsilon time
so there are a lot of incomparable
algorithms depending on the update time
and the approximation ratio
all these are all for General graphs
um yeah all of them are known for
General graphs yeah
um
there was One X
so basically like none of these
algorithms really improve the others
there's just one instance so this year
we showed with separ sanjiv and Juan
that you can slightly improve over n and
obtain n over some block start and
factor and still obtain it by myself
approximation using regularity demo but
other than this basically this was all
we knew
um no improvements over these bounds but
what happened since last year was that
we we got a basically an abundance of
new results for dynamic matching and all
of them use sublinear algorithms so this
is started with this um uh work
um that I had uh and independently uh
Cheyenne Peter tashopal and David hat uh
where we showed that you can beat half
approximation and spend only party log
time the algorithm uses sub-linear
algorithms crucially and also there's
one cache that these blue bounds would
only work for size whereas the previous
ones would only will also maintain the
edge set of damage
good
um
earlier this year
um uh Cheyenne Peter and touch up will
also showed that the one my substance
approximation can be maintained in
um
now polynomial is sublinear in end time
and to Y minus Epsilon time
um and
um
recently we showed we improved the
slightly better than half approximation
2.58 for General graphs with Amir and
Muhammad Okay so
so this is what we know
um about Dynamic matching to summarize
we had a bunch of algorithms maintaining
the matching the The Edge set of the
matching and there was a a series of
Works improving over these if the goal
is to maintain the size of the matching
instead of the edge set and all of them
use sub linear algorithms
what about condition of lower bounds
yeah that's a good question so the only
conditional lower bound that I know for
matching is for exact maximum matching
there's nothing there is no conditional
lower bound
um if you want approximate matchings
even conditional loadouts yeah
so I guess
um yeah accordingly farmer but I think
poly lock update time on my Subs
approximation
it's still potentially possible I mean
it's not ruled out
okay
other questions
nothing
multi-phase
[Music]
okay
all right um yeah as I said these blue
bounds are all
um for the size version and also they
all use something in your time
algorithms
so I tell you why something new time
algorithms are useful for Designing
Dynamic algorithms so there's a simple
reduction
um and there's a slightly more
complicated one so I'll start with a
simple reduction so first of all I'm
going to assume throughout the talk that
the size of the maximum matching at all
times is going to be linear in the
number of vertices
this assumption comes with that loss of
generality I won't tell you how but it
comes with a loss of generality
paying just polydog factors in the
update time
um so once you have this you can
maintain the matching with the lazy
approach and hit the size of the
matching with the lazy approach so the
way it works is that you approximate the
size of the matching and then you do
nothing for Epsilon n steps because the
size of the matching is linear in n with
Epsilon n steps maybe you remove Epsilon
and edges of the matching but the size
of the matching remains unchanged
approximately factors
so then you repeat this right so every
Epsilon and updates you just estimate
the size of the matching and then do
absolutely nothing for the next Epsilon
and updates maybe just change the graph
to keep track of the updates
okay
so what is the implication of this the
implication is that if we have a t time
algorithm
that Alpha approximates the size of the
maximum matching
then we get a dynamic algorithm
maintaining almost the same
approximation
in t Over N time
why because we're amortizing the this T
time over Epsilon and updates
and you can also de-amortize it if you
care about the amortization or CS bounds
um yeah but but but basically the the
idea is that you can shave off an N
factor from the running time of any
algorithm in a static algorithm and get
a dynamic algorithm
um so what is what does this imply so
basically first of all I want to mention
that if if this algorithm t
um is not sub-linear if you're gonna
spend N squared time if the graph is
dense then even if you amortize it over
n updates you're gonna still have to pay
um an update time for for for an average
update so the update time would not be
better than n and all of the previous
words really just want to get much
better than n
um so this motivates through the use of
sublinear algorithms for this uh for
this algorithm T
um
so the for example the known bounds that
I mentioned
um if you replace the half approximate
end time algorithm from 2021
you'll get a half approx almost half
approximation of the size of Maximum
chain in polyline time
if you take the slightly better than
half approximation in N to one plus
Epsilon time you get an N2 Epsilon
update time algorithm maintain it
slightly better than half these two
bands are actually not new we knew how
to do this even for maintaining the
edges of the matching this third result
is new uh this is
um what about Chariot I'll showed
earlier this year that um
you can do about myself approximation
subcate every time plugging this into
this framework basically gives about
myself approximation and now sub linear
numbers
so this is an easy reduction any
question yeah
for Epsilon n yeah I'm hiding Epsilon
dependencies
are all your uh this amortized uh no all
of these can be the amortized
yeah there is a funny trick
we can spread the computation
okay so now this is a slightly more
complicated reduction so what is a
slightly more complicated reduction
so the key intuition behind this is a
traditional starting algorithms when
they're called
they know nothing about the graph and
they have to learn about the graph
through queries okay so the algorithm
interacts with the input through queries
and that's all the algorithm knows
um
for example where is this this entry
notices that there is an edge here and
uses that somehow to estimate the size
of matching for example
but this is not the case in in the
application for dynamic graphs right so
what we can do for example is maybe we
can maintain explicitly a maximal magic
which I told you is is cheap to maintain
as we can do this in polylog update them
already
um
so what happens now is that when you
want to estimate the size of the maximum
edging in addition to learning about the
graph through these queries you also
have some information about the graph
free for free okay so this is sort of
sublinear algorithms padded with some
extra information
so
yeah so in fact this is exactly what we
do for the for beating half
approximations in polyline time we
maintain the maximum matching
um so just uh
um tell you how it works basically
um I'm going to assume uh for this
outline that the graph is bipart right
so here is here's a simple static
algorithm for beating half approximation
for Maxwell matching so the algorithm
is due to Conrad magnesium Matthew from
2012. um they they was in the study of
streaming algorithms but
it doesn't matter the Work Source in the
streaming setting all we want is that
there is a two-step simple twists
evaluating for beating half approximate
matching so how does it work so this
graph has a perfect matching the green
edges form a perfect matching every
vertex is matched
so what the convertible algorithm does
is that it first finds a maximum
matching
maximum matching may be small maybe only
half the size of a maximum matching in
case for example it picks these edges
only half of the vertices are merged
but then
um it's well known that if the matching
is only half the size of the optimal if
the max if the maximal matching is only
half the size of of the optimal solution
then nearly all edges should be in
length to the augmenting paths so in the
Second Step the algorithm tries to find
augment the short length three
augmenting paths
um
so
what it does is it first samples each
one of these edges of the first matching
with probability roughly 0.4
and marks both of their endpoints
and then finds another greedy matching
from The Mark nodes to the unmatched
vertices so this would be the second
match
so that's all that the algorithm does
first we find the maximal matching
sample some of the edges and then match
their endpoints to the unmatched verses
um so
and and it turns out that if you just
return this value which is just a
function of the size of the two
matchings
this is a 0.58 approximation of the size
of the maximum matching provided that
the graph is by part
okay 0.38 the best you can do this this
method yeah
0.58 is the is the best you can do with
it so it doesn't matter
you have to be a little bit more formal
what this method is but for a large
fraction of algorithms including this
one
um this is the best you can do
um
okay
um all right so now let's try to see how
we can use this in the dynamic setting
so the
the problem the challenge with
maintaining this is that the vertex set
of the second matching
is adaptively defined based on the
vertex set of the first matching
um
so from the perspective of a dynamic
algorithm
what this means is that updates
to the first matching m
into vertex insertions and deletions to
the graph of the second matching okay
and vertex insertions and deletions are
are
um are much harder to handle all of the
algorithms I mentioned are for Edge
insertions and deletions
um so that's that's just um go over this
so for example this is the first
matching the blue matching is the second
matching that we want to find between
the set of the match vertices to the
unmatched vertices samples match versus
the deal match versus
and now suppose that this Edge is
deleted and we maintaining a maximum
matching maybe like match this endpoint
to this other
um now what this happens is that we have
to change we have to kick this vertex
out of the set of marked vertices and
include this one except
um and this would be a Vertex insertion
in the second round vertex Sensations
are hard
um
okay
so so this is the challenge with
maintaining both matchings but together
around us you can use sublinear
algorithms the way we can use sublinear
algorithms
as as follows first of all we maintain
the matching M the first matching
explicitly using the existing
poly logarithmic time with constant time
algorithm so maximum matching
um the size then um
instead of finding the second matching
and Prime which would require
um n Square time if we want if if in one
shot we just want to compute this
matching it would require n Square time
as I told you finding the edge of any
constant approximal matching required is
linear in the number of edges times
um but instead of that suppose that we
just estimate its size and for that we
can already use the greedy half
approximate algorithm
um
which can do this in on the order and
time
okay so what what do we get so this is
for free right so this I mean for free I
mean like you spend only poly
logarithmic type per updates
so this you have for free
the second one takes order and time
whenever it's called whenever you want
to compute this up this estimate on the
size of the matching this takes on the
end time
um so overall we have an algorithm that
with an overhead of poly logarithmic
update time every time that you call it
provides a slightly better than half
approximation 0.58 approximation in
order and time now you plug this into
the lazy approach
you amortize this n cost you just call
this once do nothing for Epsilon and
updates
amortize this cost what you'll get is a
poly logarithmic time algorithm
maintaining the 0.58 approximation if
the graph is
so this was this was the whole algorithm
for beating half approximations
um and the key
um in my opinion was the use of the
sublinear algorithm
um which now I'll I'll talk more about
any questions about the dynamic
connection
is there any worry about like those sort
of
dip adversary nature of the like when
you do the sampling
that's a great question
um yes there are in fact a lot of
technicalities that I'm hiding I believe
David will talk about
um some of the important ingredients for
getting this to work against adaptive
adversaries yeah but the short answer is
yeah you can actually get this to work
against adaptive adversaries as well
okay
why can't
I can't report imagine
oh um so there's a lower bound I
actually talk about the sublinear
algorithm and then it becomes crucial
why it cannot find the map how does it
estimate the size without finding the
matching
um okay
so back to sub linear algorithms before
talking about the half approximate
linear time algorithm I first tell you a
little bit about the history of the sub
linear matching problem
[Music]
um so
the the study of Submarine algorithms
for matchings uh let's start with this
workout partners and run from 2007
um who gave an algorithm that runs in a
quasi-polynomial in the maximum degree
time Delta to the Delta 2 log Delta time
and provides an almost half
approximation so this is sublinear so
long as Delta is sufficiently small
because for example constant or even
slightly super consonant this runs in
sub linear time the size of the graph
and over time this dependency on Delta
was improved
um
an important Milestone uh was achieved
by Yoshida and Ito in stock 2009 who
showed an algorithm running in poly
Delta time uh providing half
approximation and they also showed that
you can also your normal approximation
Delta to one over Epsilon Square time
um but the problem with these algorithms
these early algorithms is that they may
all Take N Square time if Delta is not
sufficiently small so if Delta is and
then you're in and all of these
algorithms Take N Square time
um so the more modern sublinear
algorithms running something in your
time even if the maximum degree can be
as large as n
um so the first such algorithm was
um introduced by Michael uh at Al
um who gave a large constant
approximation in order and time and this
was improved over time
um yeah so I'm not going to talk about
all of these but to summarize as I
mentioned before we have three
algorithms now
um half approximation End Time study
better than half approximation and
slightly larger than end time about
myself approximation slightly smaller
account that's great
so this is about the things we know the
algorithms we know
um so now I want to tell you about
um how the half approximate algorithm
how does this first one works
um how we can obtain a half
approximation of the size of the maximum
matching in order and time and poly
login time
okay so the general idea which is
actually the same across all of these
algorithms
um is the following so you suppose that
you have some
maximum some matching M that is fixed by
some Oracle okay
um and then
the Oracle given any vertex
returns if it is matched in this
matching M and uses only Q queries okay
so this is some matching that's fixed
somewhere we do not have access to it
directly but there's some Oracle we can
ask the Oracle is this vertex Mash
inside this matching or not and there
were the Oracle spans queue time makes Q
queries and responds whether the vertex
is not sure okay so suppose that we have
this Oracle
um then the way we estimate the size of
the matching is we take T variously
sample T versus at random run the Oracle
on these two vertices
and this is the fraction of the vertices
that are matched
we multiply it by n
this will be our estimate of the number
of vertices that are matched in the
whole graph right so we basically assume
that the samples that we take represent
uh the graph the vertices of the
variable we just look at their empirical
average multiplies by the number of
vertices this gives the number of
vertices that are matching the overall
in the in the whole graph we divide by
two because we want to count the number
of edges typically in other words
okay
um so this general idea requires two
parameters to be set one is Q the time
that the Oracle takes to answer query
and see the number of samples uh for now
assume that t is constant in fact if
you're willing to pay an additive
Epsilon n error
um you can set it to either one over
Epsilon squared and um and even if you
do not want to pay another website an
error you want multiplicative
approximation so
um T would have to be slightly super
constant but it's still going to be
small okay
so the main question really now a t is a
small what is the value of Q
so what is a query complexity
for answering whether a given vertex
which in fact will be a random vertex in
this framework
as part of the matching or not and this
depends
on our choice of matching M and how the
Oracle works okay so this is this is how
the different algorithms differ
okay so um what I talk about now is the
greedy Oracle so
a greedy maximum matching is a simple
algorithm yeah
quick question are the bounds that
you're going to get like with high
probability on expectation
um that's a good question so usually the
way it works is you get an expectation
and then you repeat a couple of them
take hours and that gives you
okay okay
so okay so now take the so now I'm gonna
fix that matching M
um that the Oracle is going to tell us
if it is if a Vertex is part of it or
not so what is this matching so I will
first draw
um some suppose that we have some
permutation over the edge of the
graph if we have this permutation then
we can define a greedy maximum matching
with respect to it
as follows we go over the edges one by
one
um
uh it doesn't have any endpoints match
so you put it in a match if you greedily
every time we see an edge we put it in
the matching if it is possible so two
would want to be added to the match and
three will be and continue so on so
forth until we get this matching
so this is called the greedy maximum
measure with respect to this given
permutation
um and the output is always going to be
a maximum matching and it will result in
a half approximation of the size and any
maximum matching is at least half the
size of a maximum matching so simple to
prove so this is a good algorithm if
you're fine with half approximations
uh the question is do we actually have
an oracle that when asked about a Vertex
can provide whether the vertex is
matched or not fast
um
and
the key to designing such Oracle as this
observation the different Edge
that an edge e is in the matching
if and only if
there is no other Edge that has a lower
rank incident to that edge that's in the
matching
so for example this Edge 12 is not in a
matching because it has a lawyer ranked
neighbor 11 that is in the matching
um yeah so every Edge that's not in the
matching if you check it must have
another incident Edge that has a lower
Rank and is inside the matching
um okay and then if
you can
uh the idea for the Oracle is as follows
and this was first suggests that by
onaka new one in 2008
um so suppose that we want to know if
Edge 11 isn't the matching or not
so what they do is they recursively go
over all of the edges incident to 11.
and recursively ask if they're part of
the matching or not
um and in doing so
um
it's better to start with the edge that
has the smallest possible rank
intuitively if you draw this permutation
at random
the edges that have lower ranks have
higher probability of being part of the
matching so you want to find a match an
edge that's in the matching as quickly
as possible and terminate the process
so you start with this lowest rank Edge
neighboring 11 that would be six
they recursively call this function on
six six would query five four three two
one at this point one doesn't have any
other Edge incident to it let's add the
small rank so we immediately get that
one must be in the matching
we backtrack
to one being the matching so we will win
the matching because two is not in the
matching and it doesn't have any other
incident Edge so on so forth until going
back to 11.
so 11 now now realize that six is not
part of the matching so it would now
query the next h10
and again the same thing continues
um for 10 10 with also query nine
would backtrack to 11 and at this point
we get that 11 must actually be in the
match
um so this is actually an instance that
shows this recursive query process could
really be bad you you just export the
whole graph but if you actually start
the querying for maybe Edge 12 it would
terminate much earlier so 12 with first
query eight
would query seven seven isn't the
matching eight is not and 12 would query
9 but 9 is in the matching and we
immediately time without going through
this whole thing for 11. okay
so now the question is
um
what happens with typical vertex and if
you pick a random permutation
just a quick question here we're
querying edges as opposed to vertices
right so it's a slightly different
um that's a good question yeah so this
is the recursive query process four
edges
and for the vertex what you're going to
have to do is you're gonna have to call
this Edge Oracle on all of its edges in
the increasing order of the range
okay so yeah that's a very good question
so now let's define this quantity QV and
pi to be the number of edges that we
recursively query
um if we want to determine if a Vertex V
is matched and the algorithm According
to some computation pi
um
so onaka nuan who introduced this
recursive process showed that for every
vertex so long as this permutation Pi Is
Random
the expected size of this recursive
query tree is upper bounded by e to the
delta
um which is small when Delta is constant
so their focus was on
um constant degree graphs
um
and
um yeah yeah the intuition is to
basically count the number of monotone
paths coming out of a Vertex
um
so later on
um a year later uh they actually asked
is this title is there better analysis
and a year later Yoshida Yamamoto and
Ito showed that indeed this is uh this
can be much improved to polynomial in
Delta versus delta times the average
degree of the graph
um which is upper Bound by Delta squared
um with one additional assumption that
this vertex UV is also random so the
permutation is random the vertex that we
query is also random but this assumption
is not
um where are some because even
um in our framework anyway we take a
random vertex to run the solar column
if we test one disc to vote for any good
it's not a random vertex is there to
work on node which says that in part 18
for the Delta complexity
um I think there's a lower amount of
Delta squared
um no
um I think this is in the
um soda to any paper of copper Alpha
fatal
so if you want this to hold for any
given vertex there there's an instance
where it's at least Delta squared there
is no polynomial in Delta Opera for a
given vertex
yeah so if if you want to know what
happens for a for a given vertex that's
not random even poly Delta is not known
that's a very nice question
that's been open for for a long time
okay anyway so so what I proved was
um I tightened this
up to the login factor I show that the
same quantity for random vertex and
random permutation
the size of this recursive query tree is
upper bounded by the average degree
Times log n
and it's also lowered on the lower
bounded by average degree so the the
right answer is somewhere between
um so up to log and Factor the cell is
it
um and there's a little bit of work from
going this to the
order and time algorithm
um because here
um so you want to so you start from a
Vertex you want to recursively only call
it on the lowest rank Edge but you do
not have all of the edges so there's a
little bit of implementation
um uh details that I'm hiding but
basically this says for random vertex
you can spend average degree time know
whether it's in the matching or not and
you just run it on a constant number of
vertices this is going to give you a
half approximation with some additive
Epsilon error if you want to get rid of
the additive Epsilon and error the
number of samples would be roughly Delta
over average degree
um multiplied by this this is going to
be Delta
so the algorithm really just takes Delta
time
um
but but you have to first scan all the
degrees remove the degree zero vertices
and then it becomes Delta so it's really
just n if if there is a vertex if the
if we have the instance where the graph
is either empty or one Edge that does
really take and time it's not always
Delta but
yeah it's always all provided by n
anyway
so so I'm saying that this implies with
a little bit of implementation and
details so an algorithm that half
approximates the size of the matching
multiplicatively in order and time and
polyline time
okay
so yeah so this was how the
um
this is how the this is what the bound
the final bound was
um
I wanted to
provide some insights about the analysis
how this is prove
um but I guess in the interest of time
I'll skip this
the only thing that I want to mention is
that um
the key really is we want to analyze the
number of queries out of a Vertex this
is the quantity q that we want to bound
um and this is really hard to bound as I
said we do not even know poly Delta
Bound for a given Edge and the way to
get around this is instead of
counting the number of edges that this
given Edge queries we count the number
of vertices that actually query this
Edge so so we counted we give a bound on
the Dual
um question and that is enough
um to bound the query complexity so long
as the vertex is a as an average vertex
it took that the vertex queries a lot of
vertices
um
um but an average vertex I mean I'm not
saying that there's there's a bound but
the the proof leaves it possible that
the vertex query is a lot of vertices
um but but proves that for an average
vertex it doesn't query a lot of first
okay so I'm gonna stop here I just want
to conclude the number
yeah so for the sublinear matching
problem these are the known algorithms
um
I mentioned these three half
approximations slightly better and half
approximation approximation
for loading graphs
if you if there if if you're you're
um graph has maximum degree Delta and
think of Delta as
um not so large maybe like Delta is
smaller than N2 Epsilon squared
um then you'll see that almost an Ito
showed in Stockton 2009 that you can
obtain about myself approximation Delta
to one representative Square time
so this could potentially be better than
this if the degrees are sufficient is
okay on the lower bound side
we talked about that any constant
approximation requires Omega in time
um
any better than two-thirds approximation
requires n to 1.2 time
um and this is a new lower bound we
showed
um a few months ago that anyone has
approximation
uh requires Delta to linear and Barnabas
Epsilon number of queries
so basically this comes very close to
the
algorithm of yushirat uh the difference
is that this is Delta two one over
Epsilon Square this is Delta 2 1 over
Epsilon
um yeah so that exponent the
um
yeah the improving it at the algorithm
or the lower bound is
in my opinion a very interesting
question if I can get a tight down
um okay so so some open problems um that
I want to mention other than this is can
we get better than half approximation in
end time
um so yeah so the best on approximation
in order and time we may see this half
approximation that I just talked about
via the greedy algorithm
um you can get better than half but
you'd have to pay an additional and to
Epsilon cost
um
yeah so
obtaining better than half approximation
order and time would be extremely
interesting
or generally improving this this lower
amount maybe like you can relax this
assumption that you wanted to third
class Epsilon approximation
maybe to a small area half plus episode
approximation and that would basically
show that uh the half application is the
best
one can get in other words
um if we restrict the running time of
the algorithm to be n poly log n
the answer is at least half
approximation the right approximation is
at least half and at most two-thirds
so the answer is somewhere in between
um that's an important question in my
opinion to settle another question is
for this
um one myself approximation
um the exponent this Epsilon Prime
exponent depends on Epsilon and if you
want a really small a really good one
maybe point nine nine nine nine
approximation the running time is
probably n to 1.999 so if you wanna so
whether there is an algorithm running in
N to 1.99 time maybe has some ex maybe
have some dependencies on Epsilon still
uh maybe like times uh some f of Epsilon
another things about myself some
approximation that would be extremely
interesting I generally obtaining better
lower bounds that tight end these these
algorithms um would be an excellent
question
um okay with that I'm going to conclude
uh would be happy to answer any
questions
[Applause]
thanks I'll have a great talk I think we
have a few minutes of questions
Matrix
use the microphone
especially
you mentioned the Json C Matrix what's
the question there yeah so the
for the adjacency matrix model
um
what has written
we only know that Omega n time is needed
for any constant approximation even if
the first of all like for adjacency
Matrix if the matching is small if the
graph is either empty or one Edge you're
gonna have to square your N squared but
suppose that the matching is linear and
N now the question is what is the time
complexity so you can now ask all of
these questions
um just with the extra assumption that
the matching is linear in another piece
um and there this half approximate
algorithm still works you can still get
a half approximation in order and time
the lower the only lower amount the
lower amount all about the store around
but the the lower one that any constant
approximation requires and time also
holds
um
but the super linear lower bounds
um in and
yeah the the what's written is that the
the
they only work in the address system
list model I believe this should be
possible with the same techniques as our
um stock 23 Paper to get a super linear
and lower Bound in digestive Matrix as
well
um yeah so
okay
thanks for talk I just wanted to mention
because I kind of zoned out earlier
about the question about the lower
bounds so I want to say that there is a
stronger lower bound conditional lower
Bound for uh exact dynamic matching even
when you're trying to check if the graph
has a perfect matching so it's also in
the size case
where a support update you basically you
have to spend linear in end time even in
sparse graphs so that means linear and M
essentially so you really need to
approximate to get get these results
unless something happens
um so you showed that on average uh if
you randomly sample vertex
and other random permutation then um you
like clear a few edges I'm wondering uh
do anything about the variance of this
process like this is a very highly
evidence process
that's a good question
the proof doesn't give any bound on the
variance
are there examples where like the
variance can be very high
um
so the
the only example is the one I mentioned
to Cheyenne that there are graphs when
um
for most verses it's Delta but there's
this one specific vertex that if you
query it's going to be at least Delta
squared okay
[Applause]
foreign